what is happening there reject nation we
are here to watch the finale of witcher
season one
called much more i'm very much excited
for this both john and i are a little
bit tired at the same time though very
much looking forward to this good tv can
can pierce through the veil of sleeping
that's when you know what's good tv man
when you're forgetting all about how you
feel and you're just in it but now we
got where we're gonna be prepared for
when which for season two comes out
right thank you guys for joining us on
this very late to the party journey
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the first episode of what your
season two is up hit that like button
that helps us out the most more than
anything else and if you're interested
watch alongs where you sync up with the
time code for which are over at our
patreon page cover many shows over there
with the same tier you get the option
for reaction highlights and watch longs
included and lastly thank you to the
boys at prepper for helping us out
during this holiday season to get these
reactions up on time or in a reasonable
manner
we'll see you guys in just a few seconds
[Music]
dear diary she's my biological daughter
i will take her
protect her
and bring her back unharmed i promise
you then
what a beautiful build to timeline's
conversion i know right it's very
rewarding
your winds follow grave robbers if i was
a robber i'd be taking their belongings
butcher if i was a butcher you'd be
amongst the corpses
well played
the only thing you should do quickly is
flee
we owe it to him to do better
i'm not better sure you are gary give
yourself some credit
uh hey
[Music]
what the hell
what's going on
hey girl there you go go
home
jeez
they like revenants
gross
don't get bit
some wild ass pov shots
oh
find yourself
a uniform
oh [ __ ] it's that woman yeah
she used the voice
what happened yo that's that chick from
starship troopers
he put some respect on starship troopers
let me tell you how cold
something's in here
there was something in the air that
night
that scorch mark yeah our poor horse
[Music]
nice
[Music]
oh man you know the guy working on the
intro graphics was like
can't wait for this to open
all my work comes together
there's only one way to move north
through sodden hill we must get to the
elven keep that guards it before
nilfgaard does samaria and caidwin will
join us to defend their lands within two
days hopefully
[Laughter]
you're a talented mage
an asset to be sure
despite being a
an inconvenient [ __ ]
i couldn't have said it better myself
that's the name of her biography
do you still believe it can be saved
with some help with some damn talented
mages
those magic molotovs
[Music]
breaking bad
what's not guard's deal man just hungry
for land and power is this all we have
i'm afraid so
we tried to get more fletching but the
montage wasn't long enough
i wish i could do that
it's magic
it's not real i still wish i could do it
even if it was the real i mean it's real
enough right now
his daughter was cursed estriga you
saved her i enlisted a witcher
geralt of rivia i often wonder where
fate took him
into her
not always unpleasant
the ale won't disappoint it's the first
thing nilfgaard will destroy destroy
their eggs destroy the good ale
it's time to accept that life has no
more to give
you still have so much left to give
i'd be so mad if you enter for dice um
sir forget princess cirilla with the
channel we can take the continent enough
we will not lose her
test the brotherhood's defenses
it's just gonna be one big magic finale
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
jesus
damn she is powerful
again
[Music]
that's how i feel what a big trailer
drops
for the mages out
we will not lose to them
i did looks like carl urban with a
messed up
we can't wait for the northern kingdoms
we have to fight there are only 22 of us
now those cowards fled after tonight's
attack but i'm not going anywhere
i've lived enough i'm ready to die right
now
oh
no jake cast that was
[Laughter]
which uh
guy from new girl
oh jake johnson
[Music]
i don't like to look at this missed
butcher
it's not natural
he come back and save them all
what baby geralt
it's pretty cool it's the army of
witches like what do you got up those
sleeves
oh no
oh
dude
oh no
oh yeah i gotta get the nose yeah
whenever you use any type of telekinetic
now
wait to die
[Applause]
run away
what is that doing to them i'm not sure
[Music]
is it a similar suffocation and oh gosh
damn oh it's like acid
oh no she's got like forbidden magic up
her sleeve huh yeah no rules magic
vocal folds
now
filger force my dude
[Music]
two charged up man
no it's coming
[Music]
he might as well be alive hopefully
who am i
because i live here now
jesus christ
no
oh
man portals are cheating
we must oh sh she's going right after
her isn't she oh this is going to be to
say his last stand
you're worth more than nilfgaard can
ever give you
oh
i don't need your help
anymore
wretches
she's like the voldemort of them
uh that's not good
at all
are you okay mom i need water
go
fetch it for me
carol's was full of so much wonder i
know
i love my mom and everything's great and
everything's great all the time do not
stop
he was abandoned
[Music]
no that guy was so happy
save yourself
no
oh jesus christ
jesus christ
tris the gate can you buy us time
i don't know if i can
try anything
yes
yeah just build a wall of enemy soldiers
don't tell me she is up to no good
uh
well
what
i'm a little suspect of this
little sus
oh
so mean
what was going on dude
something not good
is she a traitor that's what i'm
thinking
oh my god yep absolutely a traitor
ah
damn it
no ah
wow
wow
[Music]
release your chaos
oh it's so brutal
[Music]
there are no limits
only power
and potential for everyone equally
tastes like juniper
burdock
yes
hey they needed to neutralize the toxins
whoa
what's happening right now
the wound was troublesome carol okay
definitely visions
to improve his eyes stop it do you know
that it doesn't always work stop it
give me that name
i need to know why my name is frank
find her
please don't go
oh damn pads
just give me a nail consider your debt
paid now can we go
[Laughter]
yeah i'm not messing with the law
surprise again
we can't give up
you saved me
hit the bottle
let your chaos explode it's not a hulk
out
you know what like one man army does yep
it's gonna let it all out
this is chaos magic wonder
[Music]
hellfire and brimstone
[Music]
wow
that should have been plan a
oh what's up my dude
oh my god there's so many of them
sleep
i'll be better in the morning
she's going to leave or something she's
like a crazy lady it's going to become
misery try to adopt me the second i get
here
yeah
oh no
she wakes up bound
it must smell awful there
jennifer
uniform
whoa damn
oh that poor woman i know she's so kind
[Laughter]
both ran off at just the right time damn
it
an orphan i found her in the woods
nearby
you gotta be [ __ ] me man
she's your destiny oh remember renfree
yeah we just saw her a few minutes ago
please tell me she's just waiting for
her yeah please let them sense each
other's she's not that far tractor or
something yeah
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
who is jennifer
oh
wow and all you poor schmucks had to
wait forever first things to do
we only gotta wait a few days
wow that would drive me nuts yeah a
hundred percent
uh driving me nutsos
what a complicated astro
yes yeah yeah yeah it does reward you
for
i imagine paying
the utmost attention but also for repeat
viewings
first episode ends with
essentially go find geralt she's your
destiny
and the last episode ends with that too
it's a good season closer yeah it's nice
bookends having it all wrap around in
the tines and i actually did an ex
because she said my husband i have a man
to match like my
my son or something like that yeah yeah
my mind started going she like a crazy
lady would doesn't really have a husband
because i haven't seen her with her
husband this whole time she made him up
yeah
she's delusional and i was trying to
recall when we first saw her if we saw
her with her husband um
because i was in the last episode
but yeah it was a nice reveal i thought
it was gonna be another like you gotta
be kidding me she's right there
right there ran away
uh and we still didn't learn really what
her powers are
no they're still they're still very
mysterious now she's got the voice
but what does that mean is that honor is
is the guy the merchant is he
honoring the law of surprise at that
moment
no because they never agreed on that all
right i think carol doesn't want to get
involved with any more surprises
i don't need to find another kid in the
woods
yeah yeah yeah
it's a good finale man yeah it's really
really crappy
i was
taking me a little bit of time to adjust
to the beginning parts especially with
the uh
didn't explain what those things were in
the woods are they
no those like just zombies yeah
revenants or something like that zombies
what zombies yeah ghouls isn't it i'm
sure somebody down there knows the exact
species from the stories sure tell us
whatever it is but yeah those that i
mean that scene alone was was
i feel like because there's not you know
obviously geralt is like out of
commission for so much of this episode i
feel like we we're owed at least one
kind of badass monster sequence
yeah we are and especially um having us
uh an extended episode it's kind of like
the marvel netflix shows
superhero shows where so you need one
episode where they're injured and
recovering yeah they're bedridden and
they can't really move they're kind of
out of it
and then the last thing i expected was
to go into geralt's pass at all it's
cool because they this show every
episode already sets up mystery and
questions pretty much every single
episode
uh
but it still
felt like they completed an arc without
fully completely they left a lot of
questions
unanswered and a lot of cliffhangers
but still feels like this specific
chapter of this journey is done because
it and really mainly jennifer's not even
in the first episode yeah as much as she
becomes like such a primary focus of the
series she's like the second episode's
mainly dedicated to her
um
that the first episode is all about
cyrilla and and geralt
so then to bookend it with this
it seems like a perfect season one
closer but it doesn't feel like a story
is complete yeah like whatsoever like
there's still so much story to it oh
absolutely it feels like in in some ways
him finding yarrow finding siri almost
feels like yeah the the beginning of the
next you know piece of the story or yeah
like the ultimate sort of here is the
beginning and it's just gonna be a fun
little comedy yes i'm learning how to be
fathered on her with each
if i had known this would be my law of
surprise i wouldn't have said a damn
thing it is weirdly emotional there at
the end because like they don't know
each other no i don't know each other at
all they just have this concept of each
other
yeah yeah yeah but i love how he
embraced her too like he held his arms
out
to accept her yeah it felt really nat
like the way they played that in the
editing and the shots and everything it
made it feel like one of those moments
where you just instinctually
yeah they instinctually embrace each
other well he's bound by honor and bound
by code
um and law at this moment
but his search just hasn't been nowhere
near as complicated as numbers because
she's been [ __ ] whirlwind
since the first episode it's just been
worse careful i'm looking for this guy
yeah and i'm getting into the most
perilous situations on this journey
because in his timeline he shows up
there it's like he's lived with the
knowledge and the weight of the
knowledge throughout all the years yeah
um but then the
you know like as you saw the last
episode he was he was just uh he was
locked up
um did cintra
and then uh like his search for her has
been nowhere hasn't been extensive yeah
like he fought to to protect her didn't
have her but then you know he gets
knocked out in the woods
and then he gets taken to
the image
and for it's funny because at first i
thought that it was gonna continue on
and that like ah ships in the night like
he's right there
and uh
and i like ultimately that you know you
get that moment of like oh no is he
about to be like recuperating here is
she just yeah so i think they did a nice
little fake out there before having like
riding off of like there are a lot of
really dreamy ethereal
sort of trance like uh interludes in
this episode and i like the way that
they drew those because it helped to
kind of aid in that
sort of telepathic mysticism of like you
already have this connection by the law
of surprise between geralt and siri but
you also have this whole situation that
seems to be
affecting all of them so when like you
know
for all intents and purposes geralt's
just been passed out on the ground but
you know he shows up in this plane of
searching for gener uh yennefer on the
you know just the hillside and things
like that and then siri knows
at least enough she must have caught a
bit of that transmission uh and so like
the kind of ambiguity but also sort of
nuance of the way they they did that
kind of helped tie that all together for
me especially with them kind of
instinctually finding each other
in the woods yeah
i thought the battle sequence was really
well realized yeah that was intense
because like we just learned about
sudden i don't really care about the
people of sodom they didn't really do
anything to make me really care um had a
couple of scenes with interacting with
some people
uh they were my favorite characters but
it wasn't like i don't really care
you care in the in the way of like oh
yeah these innocents probably shouldn't
be massacred but yeah yeah and i love
the way but i love the way they handled
it all because
it was you you get your epic finale
battle
sequence which is really well realized
and violent and really stark and
harrowing but then
what they really did was go what can we
do with our mages what can we do with
our witches and they they
they got to demonstrate a bunch of
different power sets
and watch says but the second they
started kicking ass i was like okay
they're definitely going to lose
so as they they were like whooping a
bunch of ass and you're watching like
you know like um the one guy okay his
name right now oh the vilgep vilgerberg
capilca
like am i just getting confused with
wengerberg uh
yeah villeville something
but his power set the one woman with the
almost telekinetic like powers
i'm like dealing with all all kinds of
characters you're hopping around to and
then you have jennifer pretty much
listening in playing general
guiding along the way which was really
cool and then on the flip side across
you have
[Music]
who works in a more insidious way yeah
they're very they're very forefront and
using their like they show up and do
their thing you know like blast those
crystals in the air you know
everything they're doing you can be you
can see but she works in the shadows
like using the mist using the fog sends
someone in there she sacrifices mages
the worms that literally that just seep
into you and control you like the way
she operates
is
like i said more more sneaky and i love
the way that they did that because it's
like you got all these mages pretty much
going up against one mage yeah one one
witch but yeah you're dealing with the
bat the armies of nilfgaard but the
army's enough car don't look quite
formidable towards the bay just in
comparison yeah it's like they really
need you're here to back her up yeah you
didn't really need for angela to do any
of this yeah and then you do see how
powerful she's become i do wish the show
had kind of
built up frangilla a little better um
yeah to really establish who she like
how just how much of a threat she is
yeah uh i that was one thing i did find
myself sort of craving because i would
have made this whole battle feel more
rewarding
because that's a
like i i know like i one thing i've been
saying a lot with this show is i haven't
been really having issues with the
timeline or feeling like i'm missing out
on something
uh but when you get to a finale like
this which is so you know seeped into
action
and uh chaos
but it seemed into action and the chaos
of battle
a big part of it is like other than
finding it really tense and cool i i
want to care a little bit more about
some of the stuff that's happening so i
think having like to say yennefer i
really care about that even the girl who
looks like maya rudolph what is her name
chris
yeah you knew who i was talking about
that yeah that girl looks like maya
rudolph i even kind of care about her
but i thought i just would have been
that much more elevated if i found that
witch frangilla a little more like
like she is menacing and as this episode
unveils itself more you start seeing oh
she really is
capable of being the most threatening
one of them all
um i would have found that more
rewarding but they still they won the
battle the the first battle because of
vietnam for right yeah i mean like it
seems like they all lost yeah like both
sides lost it seems like this was a
disaster for everything yeah
this is a this is a bad situation
mitigated disaster all around guys
next battle we're all going to walk out
right yeah this is a warm-up battle
yeah and i mean we see yeah cause we get
that one uh sort of moment with
formidable fringilla in the
previous episode right where they go
back to eratusa and she's like you know
come on guys i'm trying to sway all of
you you know there's no rules over here
come on and part of me i guess but you
don't really see her power set no and i
thought they might have opened up a
window of opportunity to show more of
that or or more of her yeah formidable
perspective through her appeal to
yennefer because there are parts of
yennefer
that i can see being enticed by that by
the whole like you know we're not gonna
try and restrict you and it's all about
amassing power and you know uh
and uh istred even says that to her in
that last episode about like you know
you chose power you clearly want all the
power
um so i thought they might have had an
opportunity to show a window through
there um and i'm torn because part of me
is like well i'm i guess i'm kind of
glad that jennifer was just like no i
know what's right though and this isn't
it so i got to do what i got to do well
that temptation might not fully be
passed yet
you know
like it comes closer towards the end of
the episode and she's in the midst of
losing people she really cares about
yeah
so and and i i think it's really good
how they painted
the but then again
again to kind of piggyback a little bit
off of the frangilla thing i might
actually like that we don't really see
how powerful she is until this episode
because
it kind of puts you in the audience
perspective that you might have a shot
and it always
supports every time they've slagged her
off in the previous yes yeah yeah
what's she gonna do yeah yeah yeah it
does so actually i'll i take it all back
now because it did work
in that regard like when they're first
firing those
fire witch balls whatever those life
force balls yeah essence of rage yeah
yeah that that literally kills the
witches rage made like they tossed two
and even jennifer is just like
you know yeah
okay so yeah like you know
because
yeah to look back on the experience of
this i'm now thinking
that when i was watching that i was
going okay we got a good shot
yeah my mind was thinking they got a
good shot but then as it progressed i
was like oh she actually is the really
the most powerful like she's she's one
of the most powerful ones yeah
yeah partly because there is that lack
of restriction that like well yeah she's
probably had all the great free reign in
the world to progress into areas that
you haven't even studied probably take
it all back
you don't have to yell at me now
i said both points all right yeah i mean
you know we're here in the afterglow of
the episode and and this these opinions
will continue to grow and and gather
over time but jennifer and lisa are
chaos i thought it was going to be
something weirdly
as massive of a fire explosion moment
that it was and i love this shot of just
torment and pain and like the suffrage
just exploding out of her and like
it's crazy you walk into this show going
actually individuals are probably gonna
be cool henry cavill's probably gonna be
cool
never heard of this actress in my life
he never heard anything about jennifer i
don't know rather than i saw some makeup
video about i like i never knew she was
going to evolve into hot hannaford i
thought i thought they ever seen as like
one video that touched on the makeup
that she had in episode two ages ago
that i forgot about
um
but that's all i really knew and then
you walk out and i'm like nah man it's
[ __ ] it's it's in some ways it feels
like it's her show and then it is
like so much of this the finale most of
it
centered on her absolutely and a lot of
the action like the direct action
centers around her yeah you watch this
rise to leadership and power as much as
she has been lonely at the top of her
game yeah and so much of like what she
even talks about with like i've lived
two or three lifetimes
and you know i'm kind of [ __ ] bored
uh yeah i'm like i'm i'm empty i'm
that's really what it was like i'm empty
on the at the end of the day
and
and then you see that she's never been a
team player
straight uh what's it called science no
error yeah aratuza is like something
that she has pushed away from her life
and then she welcomes it back in she
really understands better how to say a
really viewed her and i really love the
way they fleshed out that dynamic from
the very first episode of mentor mentee
and then watching how they went their
separate ways and now where where they
come at now they're not like i love you
you know they're not
there
but they total the the vulnerability of
towards each other is so much more um
out there now and maybe not in a way
that is just as like like super intimate
but you could still feel that like they
hold back on that what could be more
intimate with their expression of
respect and admiration and
uh gratitude towards one another yeah
well i love the subtleties of the way
that they've progressed especially that
relationship between the two of them
nienfer and tesaya because
there's a lot of you know we see the
origin we know that very well of you
know how harsh that was at the beginning
and in the beginning parts of this
particular episode like they're all on
the boat and clearly jennifer's like
she's going along with them but she's
the one who seems the least sort of
actually with the program she's kind of
being the most challenging and then as
the episode goes i feel like you watch
as you know they have this almost silent
understanding of each other that
continues to sort of blossom
as the chaos continues to reign and yeah
i just love the amount of
history and conflict you can see in
their back and forth and how much from
tessia is like unsaid like especially
the more you know uh supportive and the
more
uh you know affectionate feelings from
desire are very kind of reserved but you
can feel them and you can feel that
mutual like when the chips are down and
when shit's hitting the fan they know
instinctively that they can trust each
other and that they can work off the
foundation that they have together and i
think that was really beautifully
realized all across this and
you know it's like i don't know exactly
what happened to to sia when she gets
that when franzilla you know whammies
her with the cloud
yeah
but uh i was glad that she didn't just
like flat out die in this episode it
looked like she got she was very much
worse for the wear at the end of it but
uh yeah they just managed you know it's
like any time you're watching it's
requisite for a battle everyone's going
to be kind of desperate and kind of up
against the ropes but i thought they
really sold those flavors really well
and they got me feeling yeah that sort
of hopeless that that push-pull of the
hope because
you know yennefer and saya both make you
the most comfortable out of all the
other mages you're like if i'm with you
there's probably a shot
and yeah just the way that they toy with
that whole dynamic and the way that they
challenge them and uh
and that was like a really intense and
fraud and it was cool to see a battle in
a show like this obviously the
touchstone is game of thrones and you
have your big old army but i like that
this show has a more ingrained and a
more dialed up
sense of magic
uh so that yeah this battle is like it's
all magic on the mage side in a way that
feels still kind of tangible
and not like you're watching you know
like and not to slag a harry potter
movie but you know it's not the same as
watching like blazer beams and
spells
um yeah
well
this show is essentially about
witchcraft it's called witcher yeah i
still don't even know where the witcher
really is all this time and i'm like
it's an exterminator exactly as a
witcher magical creatures with like just
like a little hint of magic ability yeah
yeah
you know and i mean there's got to be
significance yeah of the fact that
witchers are called witchers yeah yeah
which in it yeah yeah no totally that's
what i mean there's like oh witchcraft
is is a big is essentially this
it is one of those like game of thrones
like epics but
witchcraft's a wrap from wizardry and
all that surrounding it
um
yeah that's good [ __ ] man good [ __ ] a
lot of cliffhangers left open yeah and
uh a lot of people alive
and we're gonna uncover geralt's
backstory a little bit more yes and
little boy girl geralt yeah i mean i
don't think they would do a timeline
thing now would they
like it would it make but if they want
to just like brand new season start a
brand new story because i'm like you're
in a perfectly good place to now just do
uh
just a linear storytelling yeah because
jennifer is like
30 minutes away
yeah yeah yeah and it seems like
looking back just here and now it seems
like yeah the things that we jumped
around in time to get
are all this sort of necessary context
to help inform when everybody does start
to collide on them you know present
together true true so yeah i'm curious
to know how they approach time i feel
like there's gotta be some time jumping
we have no idea what season two looks
like yeah yeah
um like there's gotta be some element of
time jumping but i would be surprised if
it's not more present and more serial in
that regard yeah right i get you
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below you can subscribe click that
bell hit that like button check us on
patreon and
catch y'all soon
[Music]
you